here's this little sauce right here dawn
hearts what's up with this
diamond who's this sugar biscuit and
that king in this thing merch that
obviously
was made by a company that's not even
ours yes
that was a fraudulent shirt we did not
make some guy came up to me and uh i was
like dude
and i like i know we've never even made
that shirt
and it was awesome that's the worst part
of it
oh it's awesome man
so hi theo hi brynden i have a debate
club for you guys
eyeglasses or contacts let me know
gang gang buzz buzz
tits
brendan this is an adult woman okay
children crazy she's definitely a mom
what do you mean you're what are you
talking about now you talked about her
tits immediately don't act like we
didn't remember that no that was a while
that wasn't my first go-to
her tits were not i think my grandma's
on theo's baseball team
oh [ __ ] look at that hey nick
i think your grandma's the shortstop
we are members of the all-american
league
we come from cities near and far
we're canadian we're irish and we're
asian we're all for one we're one for
all we're all american
is that from a league of their own yep
that's our squad baby
the racing bells dude that's wisconsin
isn't it yes it is
that's right then that little [ __ ]
trailer system stop dude what's your
grandmother's name
kathryn link that's catherine link maybe
our old shortstop
k-link they called her k-link we tell
kalyn get her [ __ ] mind right because
let's be throwing heat at her dumb ass
[Laughter]
what are you talking about that's an
adult lady that's a double adult
double her her nickname and this was
actually like uh
she had like a cv name i don't know
people did it was missing link
that's hard it's also a movie
cartoon oh glasses are contacts though
glasses or contacts i think i would go
i can't wear glasses because i have a
big nose it looks like i have a disguise
on
so that's one of the worst things i'm
glad you said i'm glad you said it
oh i've had glasses on this whole show
yeah i didn't even realize it dude
yeah man i was i kept thinking jesus
what is in here what is different
[Laughter]
this um yeah i if i put him on it i feel
like it
that's the shitty part about having a
bigger nose you can't have a disguise no
what about on girls you like girls with
glasses i like with glasses
the fun part is you can pick you can
actually pick and you can actually pick
your nose if you have a little note like
you suddenly you'll see people picking
there's like their pinky dude
that person is a of weird that's scary
yeah yeah the little nose you got
your nose with your pinky i think that's
the weirdest [ __ ] that's like you're so
rich you barely want to get in there
you got no choice but getting nothing
get in that [ __ ] son oh yeah
what i'm saying three fingers and this
oh dude if it was cold
out at the bus stop i'd [ __ ]
both my hands off there
[Music]